foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar it is
called Multiplex proteomics using
proximity extension assay for
identification of protein biomarkers
predictive of acute graft versus host
disease in allogenic hemopoietic stem
cell transplantation
my name is daily yazuki I'm from all
link proteomics I'll be today's
moderator
this particular web seminar is presented
by labroots it's brought to you by olent
proteomics I'd like to just take a few
moments at the beginning of this webinar
to talk about o-link in general
our new slogan is revealing the truth of
human disease protein by protein and
what all link proteomics offers is a
remarkable assay called the proximity
extension assay that is scalable from a
handful of protein biomarker targets to
literally thousands it's a form of amino
PCR where DNA is conjugated to
antibodies and as you can see from the
diagram on the left there's a pair of
antibodies that lend Exquisite
specificity and sensitivity the readout
is via actually a DNA
that's barcoded and as you see from the
hybridization of the DNA it's the
proximity of two different antibodies
against the same protein biomarker that
end up being Amplified as a DNA digital
readout signal
and what we've been able to do is use
this particular technology that offers a
unique set of benefits around three
particular kinds of products which we
call explore which is three thousand
biomarkers Target we have 15 panels of
96 Plex uh protein bar marker targets as
well as a 48 flux we have o link Flex
which is a 20 Plex where you choose you
mix and match from 15 to 21 targets out
of a library of 200 and focus which is a
complete custom panel the bottom right
shows a software package we call o-link
Insight that gives you pathway
information to help the analysis of all
this protein biomarker data and just to
illustrate this graphically in terms of
what explorer does Target and flex this
particular pea technology scales from
like I mentioned 3000 all the way down
to a completely custom panel and the
beauty of the technology is that it's
built to scale both in terms of marker
number as well as samples
lastly just the slide points out that
the technology gives High sensitivity
wonderful specificity uses very small
amounts of sample which for some
applications becomes really important
and a very wide dynamic range
we have the privilege of hearing from Dr
Frank mcallis uh he's from Princess
Margaret Cancer Center in the department
of medicine at the University of Toronto
and Frank you may now begin your
presentation
thank you Dale thank you so much for
your kind introduction
I'm going to speak to you today about
protein biomarkers that are predictive
in acute graft versus host disease in
allergenic stem cell transplantation
um this is the hospital where I work at
I am a staff hematologist and associate
professor with the University of Toronto
and I'm at the Princess Margaret Cancer
Center where we perform over 200
allogenetic stem cell transplants per
year
um we are the uh one of the largest um
allogenetic transplant uh centers for uh
adults in Canada
these are my disclosures
and during the course of today's talk
um we will devote uh some time to
overview what allergenic stem cell
transplant is
um as well as one of the major
complications of transplant which is
acute graft versus host disease we will
also run over a few of the fundamentals
of biomarker discovery
and we will look into the use of
proteomics analogenic transplant and
biomarker research in particular in the
context of
um predicting acute graft versus host
disease
so this is a brief overview of what it
is that we do um in allogenic stem cell
transplantation
um
allogenetic transplant is reserved
mostly for malignant hematological
diseases however also for some benign
hematological diseases as well such as
aplastic anemia and in brief what we do
is we administer conditioning
chemotherapy
um which targets leukemic cells as well
as creates room in the bone marrow for
the expansion of the stem cells which
are infused on Day Zero following which
is a prolonged uh course of aplasia
um where patients are vulnerable to
infections and other complications until
the time of engraftment upon engraftment
of the um stem cells and reconstitution
of the peripheral blood counts patients
are then discharged however
complications can still occur including
graft versus host disease and other
types of infections
so the more frequent um complications of
stem cell transplantation include the
conditioning regimen toxicity Vino
occlusive disease of the liver multiple
infections as I previously mentioned
graft failure of course
um and graft versus host disease and
graft versus host disease is one of the
most significant and potentially
devastating
complications that can occur after
transplant and as we perform more and
more allergenic transplants every year
you see here this graph from the center
of international bone marrow transplant
Research Center demonstrating how
exponentially the number of oligenetic
transplants increase along with that we
see a significant increase in the
complications including acute graft
versus host disease
now why does acute graft versus host
disease even occur we see this when
um the transfer of tissues between
normal individuals occurs
the recognition and destruction of this
foreign tissue is known as the host
versus graft effect which is what leads
to graft failure however there are
immunologically competent cells in the
graft and these can initiate an
immunological recognition in the
direction of the host hence graft versus
host disease
it affects up to 60 percent of
ologenetic transplant recipients and can
account for up to 20 percent of deaths
in this population and again here we see
some data from the CIB MTR demonstrating
that
um in both the fully matched sibling
donor transplant setting as well as the
unrelated donor transplant setting uh
cbmtr uh the gvhd accounts for
um approximately 20 one-fifth of uh
deaths
now for graph versus host disease to
develop there are certain requirements
um sort of fundamental principles of how
gbhd occurs the record the first
requirement is that the graph must
contain immunologically competent cells
so these are mature T cells that are
present in the sun in the stem cell
graft and it has been found that the
number of donor T cells that are infused
in The graft correlates with the
severity of um graft versus host disease
the second requirement is that the
recipient of these uh T cells must be
incapable of mounting an offense
effective defects so the most frequent
setting in which we see graft versus
host diseases in the allogenetic
transplant setting
um and there are certain risk factors
associated with that which we will
discuss further down
um
more rarely we can see in solid organ
transplants or certain solar organ
transplants you can see the occurrence
of Graphics host disease particularly in
small bowel transplant and very rarely
fortunately
this can occur even with a simple blood
transfusion such as with non-radiated
blood products administered to neonates
or immunosuppressed patients or even
blood donation from one uh relative to
the next
the third requirement for the
development of graft versus Source
disease is that the recipient must
Express tissue antigens that are not
present in the donor and the tissue
antigens that are most important here
are the human leukocyte antigen
um system which are products of the
major historical compatibility complex
and these are expressed on all cells and
are particularly important for T cells
other antigens that are also significant
in the development of graft versus host
disease are the minor history
compatibility antigens they can also be
recognized as foreign
and these discrepancies in antigen
expression
um are what's responsible for the
development of gvhd it can even occur
between genetically identical
individuals as epigenetic changes after
birth can also lead to differences in
expression of certain antigens so the
HLA
antigen system is encoded in the short
arm of chromosome six and basically it
is what we um try to match donors and
recipients with um in order to decrease
the chances of graft versus host disease
and graft rejection and basically we'll
look at matching at class one HLA that's
HLA a b and c as well as Class 2 Dr and
DQ antigens
non-hla genetics are also involved I've
previously mentioned minor histal
compatibility antigens as well as the
kir gene system and even differences in
um single nucleotide polymorphisms
um in relate related to cytokine genes
cytokine receptor genes or cytokines
related to the innate immune system
now how does graft versus host disease
develop
um it is believed that the initial the
initial tissue injury occurs with the
conditioning chemotherapy regimen
um this damages
um host tissues and in particular of the
gastrointestinal tract or the skin or
the liver among other among other uh
organ systems this host tissue damage
releases a number of cytokines such as
tnf Alpha il1
and local polysaccharide which leads to
the activation of the host antigen
presenting cells these host answers
you're presenting cells interact with
donor T cells
um activating them and ultimately
leading to Cellular inflammatory
um responses that lead to Target cell
apoptosis and ultimately tissue and
organ damage
B cells also play a role in the
development of graft versus host disease
via antigen presentation cytokine
secretion and antibody production now
the immune system does have mechanisms
of central deletion of autoreactive T
cells in order to moderate these
inflammatory responses leading to gvhd
um loss of the normal thymic repertoire
contributes to development of gvhd
um
Fox P3 regulatory T cells or so-called
t-regs they're found to be very
important in suppressing graft versus
host disease but a loss of these
regulatory T cells is associated with um
worsening grade of graft versus host
disease
now graft versus host disease can be
classified as acute or chronic this
classification
um is sort of historically being defined
as acute occurring up to day 100 after
stem cell transplantation and chronic
after day 100 however you can have late
acute onset of graft versus host as well
as early classic chronic manifesting as
so-called overlap syndrome we're going
to focus mostly on the acute graft
versus host disease in this talk
so acute gvhd primarily affects
um just a few organs that we're going to
focus on
um skin is affected in around 81 percent
of patients that develop acute gbhd and
in 44 of cases just the skin
so this can manifest as
um mostly more frequently as a
maculopapular rash or even a diffuse
erythema
um the extent of which we use to
determine the stage and ultimately the
grade and severity of acute gvhd
uh the differential diagnosis of a 2gbhd
of the skin also includes
um things like
um
toxicity the chemotherapy or
um viral infections or reactions to
drugs
and histologically what we see is
lymphocytic cytosis into the epidermis
as well as the presence of apoptotic
keratinocytes
a qgvhd very frequently also affects the
gastrointestinal tract in around half of
the cases and histologically what we see
again here are apoptotic bodies in the
base of the crits crypt abscesses and
the loss and flattening of the surface
epithelium
clinically what we see in lower GI gvhd
is abdominal cramping and pain of
significant high volume diarrhea
um hematochezia as well as a possible
ileus and more severe cases and the
severity of GI gbhd is determined by the
volume of diarrhea however there are
numerous other diseases that need to be
included in the differential such as C
diff colitis CMV arthritis or even post
chemo radiation effect that usually
occurs in the first two weeks after
transplant
qgvhd can also manifest in the upper GI
um it's a variant of gig vhd manifesting
as nausea vomiting anorexia and
dyspepsia
and the differential here can also
include viral infections such as HSV or
Canada esophagitis gastritis and chemo
radiation effect and the best way to
determine what the etiology is is of
course pathologically by uh biopsy
um then we have liver gvhd which also
manifests in about 50 of the cases and
um this histologically is manifesting as
damage to bile kind of liquid and
cholestasis
um the differential includes Vino
occlusive disease toxicity from
chemotherapy as well as viral infection
from a variety of viruses
now what are the risk factors for gvhd
because the risk risk is uh different
from Patient to Patient and depends on
factors that are related to the
recipient the donor The graft that we
Infuse for the transplant or the actual
transplant procedure
so um older age of the recipient
um
can predispose to worse acute graft
versus host disease as well as what I
mentioned previously HLA compatibility
with the donor
um minor histo compatibility antigen
differences as well as sex uh the
difference
um and particularly when the donor is a
female and the recipient is male we see
there that there is an increased risk of
acute graft versus host disease now
related to The graft uh the use of
um gcsf mobilized peripheral blood stem
cells as opposed to bone marrow graft
that predisposes to acute gvhd a higher
stem cell count
is predisposing to
um uh worsening grade acute G of HD
while the use of T Cell depletion
decreases the chance of gbhd
and as far as the transplant procedure
is concerned reduced intensity
conditioning actually predisposes less
through acute gvhd compared to
myeloblative conditioning regimen
now
um when acute gvhd develops
um depending on the organ or organs
involved and the extent that they're
involved we can determine the grade and
thus the severity of the acute G of HD
for skin it depends on the amount of
body surface area that is involved for
liver it depends for the most part on
the bilirubin levels
and as far as gut gvhd is concerned it
is related to the volume of diarrhea so
depending on the grade on the stage then
we can determine what the grade is of
gbhd with grade one the lowest grade of
a qg of HD being just involving the skin
and this can actually be treated with
topical steroids alone
or you can have grade two to four acute
HD which is treated with systemic
steroids
now depending on the grade of acute gbhd
um we see a higher incidence of
treatment-related mortality with the
high grade acute gbhd grade four of
course being associated with the worst
mortality
however gvhd also has a potential
demonstrates a potential benefit
of these so-called graph versus leukemia
effect and Studies have shown that
patients that demonstrate both acute and
chronic gvhd ultimately have a higher
leukemia free survival
um and overall survival while patients
that do not demonstrate graft versus
host disease at all might be
um spared from the this complication and
the side effects of treatment however
they do have significantly higher
relapse rates
now in order to
um the best treatment of gvhd uh is of
course the prevention of gbhd so we're
going to talk a little bit about the
prophylaxis and the first step in
protecting from gbhd has to do with the
use of the donor so for both acute and
chronic graft versus host disease match
sibling donors have a lower incidence of
a qg of HD compared to unrelated donors
while um gbhd prophylaxis is probably
one of the most important interventions
um in the transplant process
um it's the best strategy to minimize
graft versus host disease and of course
the immunosuppression we administer
protects from uh graft rejection as well
this prophylaxis decreases the incidence
and the severity of gvhd however it does
not completely eliminate the development
of gvhd
and
um there's a variety of combinations of
immunosuppressive drugs that we use to
protect from development of graft versus
host disease and these include
calcinurian Inhibitors such as
cyclosporin or cochrolinus combined with
Methotrexate or other drugs as well
um x-vivo T Cell depletion is also being
used and more recently
um
I think more frequently uh transplant
centers are now using post-transplant
cyclophosphamide or other forms of in
Vivo T Cell depletion to protect from
gvhd
talcinorin Inhibitors such as
cyclosporine are a Cornerstone in the
protection against graft versus host
disease they were introduced into our
practice since the mid 1980s and were
basically a game changer as up until
then gvhd was a very significant cause
of very high grade graft versus uh host
disease and uh and mortality
calcinor Inhibitors are administered
from day minus one of transplant that's
one day before the stem cell infusion
and um for the most part they are used
for prophylaxis up to around three
months after the transplant
so the question here being in regards to
prophylaxis how much do we administer so
one can be aggressive with the
immunosuppression in protecting against
graft versus host disease however
um the more aggressive prophylaxis might
lead to less graft versus host but will
predispose to more relapse especially
with the aggressive hematological
malignancies such as the leukemias while
decreasing prophylaxis can protect from
relapse post-transplant however you
would be faced with more higher chance
of severe graft versus host disease so
it is a delicate balance that we try to
achieve
more recently post-transplant
cyclophosphomide has been
um introduced as graft versus host
disease prophylaxis and it has been
quite successful this is one of the
early Publications by canarkan
colleagues from 2014 where they
successfully used
post-transplant cyclophosphamide as the
sole graft versus host disease
prophylaxis given a day three and day
four after the stem cell infusion and
what they saw was a significant decrease
in acute graft versus host disease in
particular the grade three and to four
more devastating graft versus host
disease as well as chronic and not for
Source disease and without a significant
increase in relapse risk
regarding treatment of acute graft
versus host disease acute G of HD must
be treated aggressively like I mentioned
previously grade one isolated skin gbhd
can be treated with topical steroids
Alone
um but for grade two to four acute gvhd
systemic steroids are used and high
doses of systemic steroids in particular
for grade three to four and of course
depending on response a steroid paper is
initiated as steroids have well-known
and significant multiple different
um complications
unfortunately up to 30 percent of acute
ghd patients are steroid refractory so
steroid refractory acute gvhd is defined
as progression of gvhd within three to
four days of initiation of treatment or
no improvement within a week or an
incomplete response within 14 days or by
day 14 of initiation of treatment in
that case
the stereo Factory gvhd is unlikely to
resolve with that treatment alone and
requires second line treatment and
unfortunately these patients have a very
poor survival
there's a variety of Treatment available
for steroid refractory gvhd and
um
multiple different immunosuppression
treatments have been used
um
including polyclonal and monoclonal
antibodies on phototherapy or even extra
corporeal photophoresis
there's multiple studies out there
demonstrating some response of these
patients but overall the prognosis is
dismal even if gvhd is brought under
control these patients usually succumb
to multiple infections
and this sort of underscores why
prediction of gvhd is so important
which brings us to the um prognostic
methods
that can be used in predicting
allergenic transplant outcomes and in
particular uh graft versus host disease
so pre-transplant risk scores have been
developed and validated
um however differences from uh
transplant center to Center seem to
demonstrate that these prediction scores
are not very uh applicable
all across the board machine learning
algorithms is also being developed in an
attempt to predict outcomes such as
graph versus host disease however I
think the major player in G of HD
prediction is the study of biomarkers
so a few words about biomarkers and what
is a biomarker by definition a biomarker
is a characteristic that is objectively
measured and evaluated as an indicator
of normal biological processes
pathogenic processes or pharmacologic
responses to a therapeutic intervention
biomarkers
um can be very useful also in clinical
trials while in clinical trials we
investigate clinical endpoints that
measure distinct
characteristics of a disease that
reflect the therapeutic effect however
biomarkers can serve as a surrogate
endpoint that substitutes the clinical
endpoint and helps even predict clinical
effects
biomarkers um in medicine are seen
everywhere
um just about anything that can be
measured in a patient can be used as a
biomarker they we see them as diagnostic
tools such as measurement of blood
glucose in patients with diabetes
um disease staging such as cancer
markers and even
um Imaging
can indicate prognosis such as the
extent of tumor shrinkage after
administration of chemotherapy
biomarkers
um as defined by the NIH can be
categorized as Diagnostic in which case
they can help a clinician differentiate
diseases with similar clinical
presentations they could be prognostic
um and help determine the likelihood of
developing a particular complication
they can be categorized as predictive in
which case they give information on how
patient will respond to particular
treatment and they can also be used to
measure the response the adequacy of a
response to a certain treatment
biomarkers can be derived from just
about any biological material blood
urine saliva and imaging can all be used
as biomarkers
however the ideal biomarker needs to be
readily available
as um non-invasive as possible the
method and easily collected at various
time points and the biomarker source
that fits the bill here is uh blood and
plasma
um it seems to be the most common source
of biomarkers and what is most commonly
used in biomarker research
now in the development of the biomarker
there are multiple steps involved the
first step being the identification of
potential biomarker candidates
um the the identification phase is
usually performed in a small cohort of
patients maybe 40 to 50 patients
um where um a potential biomarker is
identified that correlates with a
specific type of clinical manifestation
this is verified in a larger independent
cohort and finally the qualification
phase of testing the impact in a large
population usually multi-center
so while investigating for biomarkers
specifically for graft versus host
disease confounding factors
um
should be considered when choosing
samples and controls these involved the
grade of uh graft versus host disease
and the target organ involved
factors related to the immune
reconstitution after transplant the uh
whether the patient's on
immunosuppression or not and concurrent
infections for instance as well as
factors related to sample processing and
Storage
and when analyzing the impact of
biomarkers
um covariates should be investigated as
well that are related to the transplant
um and the patients such as patient age
the primary disease the patient is
transplanted for endonor characteristics
such as the donor type and the HLA
matching as well as conditioning regimen
conditioning intensity and the use of
immunosuppression
now the ideal biomarker
should be both sensitive and specific
sensitivity is defined as the proportion
of patients with a Target condition in
whom the test is positive and
specificity is the proportion without
the target condition in whom the test is
negative now a plot of the true positive
rate versus the false positive rate of
all possible thresholds of a biomarker
is the receiver operator characteristic
or the ROC curve and the area under that
Roc curve is a very commonly used
measure of the utility of a biomarker
and it is a number that ranges from 0.5
to 1
um with 0.5 demonstrating no diagnostic
capability and one being the ideal
associated with the ideal diagnostic
discrimination
now um regarding protein biomarkers
specifically for graft versus host
disease
um I'd like to uh elaborate a little bit
on that
um many different immune mediated
um
proteins related to development of graft
versus host disease have been studied
over the years
um and found to correlate with the
degree of gvhd il-12 for instance an
il-18 promote the th1 lymphocyte
development and acute graft versus host
disease
and this study demonstrates how il-12p
70 levels in the first month after
transplant are associated with grade two
to four acute gvhd
other immune cell derive biomarkers
include tnf receptor one which in this
study was measured at Baseline as well
as day seven this is a surrogate for tnf
Alpha and it seems that patients whose
levels decreased above 2.5
times compared to Baseline these
patients demonstrated uh they developed
grade two to four acute HD significantly
interleukin-6 is also another
pro-inflammatory immune cell derived
um uh cytokine that has demonstrated to
correlate with the um uh severity of
acute graft versus host disease
and some other Studies have looked at
multiple different cytokines
simultaneously such as this one where
the cumulative incidence of grade three
to four acute G of HD was seen in
patients um with versus without elevated
biomarkers by day 15 post transplant
anti-inflammatory cytokines also can be
useful as biomarkers for acute graft
versus host disease for instance TGF
beta which promotes the generation of
regulatory T cells that dampens the um
severity of graft versus host disease
however the elevation of this cytokine
can indicate
um a reaction of the patient's body to
the inflammatory response of graft
versus host disease the same thing with
il-10 which is a macrophage and th1
cytokine inhibitor these levels of these
cytokines seem to be increased when gvhd
develops
now um we are not going into uh deeply
um to discuss chronograph versus host
disease but these types of biomarkers
can also be uh isolated from the serum
um predictive of chronic gvhd as well so
in this study b-cell activity factor or
bath was investigated in 104 patients
bath levels significantly were higher in
octave chronic graft versus host disease
patients and this um biomarker also
seems to be elevated in other autoimmune
diseases as well
Auto antibodies have also been studied
in The Chronic gvhd setting this is an
older study looking at a small number of
patients however it demonstrated that
patients that had chronic gvhd also had
circulating Auto antibodies which
control patients did not
another type of a protein biomarker
isolated from a serum that could be
predictive of graft versus host disease
involves tissue injury divide biomarkers
um elephant for instance which is
released from keratinocytes cyto keratin
18 from epithelial cells reg 3A which is
released from damage of the intestinal
epithelium and specifically from Panic
cells as well as hepatocyte growth
factor and sd2 which is released from
endothelial cells
another potential biomarker is um the
proteins belonging to the heat shot
protein family
um in particular the 70 kilo Dalton heat
shock protein is upregulated in
inflammation and autoimmunity
and has been found to be involved in the
production of pro-inflammatory cytokines
so this is another potential biomarker
that can be studied or even a potential
Target for a treatment of acute gvhd
now more recently
plasma biomarker panels have been
utilized in order to investigate
um and identify potential
um protein biomarkers and allergenic
transplant recipients
in this study
antibiomicroarrays for 120 different
proteins were studied in blood samples
that were drawn on multiple time points
um post-transplant and within 24 hours
of development of graft versus host
disease in this study 42 patients were
investigated 21 with graft versus host
disease and 21 without
and among these multiple potential
biomarkers
um eight candidate proteins were
identified and using Eliza methodology
the they were tested on 424 patients
that were separated into a training site
and a validation set and logistic
regression analysis
um helped the researchers derive a four
marker panel which involved interleukin
to receptor tnfr1 il-8 and hgf and these
four proteins in combination this panel
was predicted with a pretty high AUC of
0.86
plasma biomarkers and uh using
um sort of Multiplex panels have also
been uh performed in chronic gvhd in
this study 35 patients with chronic gvhd
were compared with 18 patients without
and 105 candidate proteins were
investigated with four lead biomarkers
which demonstrated a good predictive
score of almost 0.9
which brings us now to
um probably what is the largest
proteomics study
um that is ongoing worldwide in regards
to allogenetic transplant recipients and
prediction of acute graft versus host
disease that is the magic Consortium
magic stands for the Mount Sinai qgvhd
International Consortium it involves
over 25 stem cell transplant centers and
it provides consistent multi-center
monitoring of acute gmhd severity during
treatment
as well as its main purpose is to obtain
samples for biomarker analysis so this
Consortium has enrolled over 4 000
patients and they've collected more than
000 serum samples to date
um our Center actually has recently been
accepted into this Consortium and we are
on the verge of starting to collect uh
samples uh as well and participate in
this um in this multi-center um
collaboration
now the purpose of the magic Consortium
is to investigate biomarkers potentially
predictive in acute gvhd but also to
help incorporate these biomarkers into
clinical trials
um because of this interest in clinical
trials and the standardization of acute
gvhd criteria they've modified their
qgvhd criteria a bit to include
um things like upper GI gbhd for
instance and also they've modified how
lower GI ghd has uh is being assessed
all this is in the context of
incorporating
um these criteria into the clinical
trials that are derived from this
Consortium
uh before I get into the results of what
these this Consortium has already
published I'd like to say a few more
words about acute ghd of the lower GI
and
um the mechanisms behind it so acute
gvhd
targets the gastrointestinal Crypts
which
um hosts intestinal stem cell stem cells
that are found in the crypts of the both
of those small and large bowel
in these Crypts also we find the planet
cells which contain iosinophilic
granules with antimicrobial peptides
um as well as the regenerating eyelid
derived protein 3A otherwise known as
reg 3A and the function of these cells
is that they generate proliferation
signals for the intestinal stem cells
also in the crypts we have innate
lymphoid cells which are a cluster it's
called cryopatches and these are ilcs
they secrete il-22 which in turn
secretes stimulate secretion of reg3a by
the Panic cells and helps expand the
intestinal stem cells which is important
when on the intestinal mucosa gets
damaged such as in situations like acute
gvhd now the histological severity of
gig of HD depends on the damage
um and the amount the number of the
individual crits that are destroyed
um
the Panic cells that I previously
described are both targets and shields
of the GI Crypt against graft versus
host disease and the loss of these cells
correlates with the increased clinical
severity of gvhd
therefore the reg 3A is released into
the bloodstream when these Crypts are
damaged by ghd and the serum levels of
this protein increase as the severity of
gvhd increases
um another
um protein axis that can be used as
potential biomarkers is the il-33 sd2
axis il-33 is a protein an alarming that
is released by damaged cells and levels
are found increased during graft versus
host disease and the membrane bound sd2
suppressor suppressor of tumorogenesis
the receptor of il-33 is expressed on
activated T cells as the ghd progresses
serum levels of st2 our powerful
predictive markers in severe gvhd in
humans
so
these two markers in particular they're
of particular significance they were
assessed along with a few other
potential significant proteins in this
study launched by the magic Consortium a
multi-center study which basically
comprised a training set of 492 patients
and a test set of 300 patients where
samples were collected within 40 48
hours before or after treatment was
started for qg of HD so they focused
just on a handful of potentially
significant biomarkers il-2 receptor
tnfr1 reg 3A alafin and sd2 measured by
Eliza and among these sd2 rank3a a tnfr1
perform the best
so
um
based on those three serum biomarkers a
prognostic score was developed using
this algorithm which calculates the
probability of non-relapse mortality and
depending on the
um
probability of non-relapse mortality
they were categorized into these three
groups and Arbor one with an nrm of less
than 10 percent and Arbor II of an nrm
of intermediate non-related mortality
and nrm uh over 40 for the group called
Ann Arbor 3. and what they demonstrated
is that these groups uh Ann Arbor one
two and three were predictive of
non-relapse mortality and overall
survival in the training set the test
set as well as the validation set while
incidents of relapse was not affected
demonstrating that these biomarkers
predictive of non-reliance mortality due
to gvhd had no connection to the graph
versus leukemia effect
um these um Ann Arbor groups these
prognostic groups also were predictive
of complete remission or partial
remission of qgvhd by day 28 and this
was seen again in the training set the
test set and the validation set
um
and what was also really interesting was
that even in the low risk group
of uh acute gvhd again these Ann Arbor
groups were able to stratify into high
risk of uh death and low risk
so this algorithm demonstrated the
ability to define the risk despite
differences in clinical severity and
that means that even in a more
clinically severe acute gvhd a low Ann
Arbor score means that we can taper the
the steroids sooner while a high score
um
would benefit from more intense
immunosuppression
in a different study Again by The Magic
Consortium this involved patients
transplanted from 2005 to 2015 and they
had provided blood samples for
biobanking at seven days post-transplant
again we had a large training set and a
test set as well as a validation set
looking at sd2 reg3a tnfr1 and IL to ra
by Eliza
and they found that the sd2 combined
with reg 3A measured at that time Point
best predicted six-month non-relapse
mortality
um stratifying patients into high risk
and low risk groups and this was seen
again in the training set the test set
and the validation set
um and interestingly this was also
um uh consistent in the subgroups
depending on whether the donors were
related or unrelated
um matched or mismatched
um reduced intensity or full intensity
conditioning chemotherapy and
irrespective of age
so they developed using just these two
biomarkers st2 and reg 3A a refined Ann
Arbor scoring system predictive of
non-relapse mortality
now um the ability to predict using
these Ann Arbor groups is important as
it can be used to identify high-risk
patients in clinical trials such as this
one so this was a biomarker guided
pre-emptive
um uh uh assessment of a steroid
refractory a graft versus host disease
patients that were treated with alpha-1
anti-scription in previous
um stage one
two clinical trials
um these patients uh demonstrated a
response to alpha-1 antithrypsin so this
study wanted to investigate further and
see if stratifying
um preemptively the high-risk patients
can lead to a lower
um uh
frequency of steroid refractory graft
versus host disease unfortunately this
trial failed so despite the um
identification of the high risk patients
this drug did not decrease the chance of
steroid refractory graft versus host
disease however as a proof of principle
this demonstrated how using biomarkers
we can guide clinical trials and develop
develop clinical trials to identify
treatments that can prevent steroid
refractive gvhd
um now before I go on to more Multiplex
methods um used in gvhd um prediction I
just wanted to differentiate between the
transcript home and the proteome while
the transcript tone looks at the genome
or the MRNA complement found within a
cell the proteome characterizes all the
proteins of uh of a cell in terms of
localization post-translational
modifications and interactions at any
given time and thus gives a sort of um
snapshot of what is currently going on
um in in a patient and the uh
pathophysiological mechanisms that are
at Play
um
Dale has already
um shown you an introduction to the um
Multiplex proteomics using the o link
method the proximity extension assay
um is an immunoassay panel that's
coupled with DNA methodology it's highly
specific High Multiplex rapid throat uh
biomarker analysis which uses matched
pairs of antibodies which bind to a
specific protein and each antibody
carries a DNA tag
the match DNA strands in close proximity
they hybridize and combining this dual
antibody binding and DNA barcoding this
provides a scalable method with very
high specificity because only the
correctly the correctly hybridized tags
are extended and Amplified
and we used our Center of this method in
order to investigate
um and to screen for potential
biomarkers in acute graph for social
disease patients following transplant
um this was a study done by myself and
Dr Van pasik as principal investigators
and in collaboration with the Mount
Sinai Hospital
laboratory here at uh at the University
of Toronto
what we did was we looked at 28 patients
which underwent a low genetic transplant
for acute myelody leukemia in First
Complete remission we preemptively
collected samples from day minus six day
Zero and different time points
post-transplant
and we investigated 17 patients that had
developed grade two to four or two gbhd
and compared them with 11 patients
without
um graft versus host disease and here's
just a snapshot of the um two patient
populations
um involved in the study
after an initial study we did a pilot
study using only 10 patients
using the um 1000 Multiplex o-link
platform we identified
552 proteins which we would use for a
more extended uh uh cohort these involve
the seven o-link panels the
cardiovascular two regulation metabolism
neural exploratory neurology oncology
and immune response panels
so what we did was using this more
limited o-lig panel We performed um
analysis of samples at Baseline and at
the time point right before development
of graft versus host disease in the gvhd
cohort and we compared them to the uh
control cohort where samples were
analyzed at Baseline and at the last
time time point that a sample was
collected
and we performed two different types of
analysis of the results one was an
individualized analysis where protein
candidates with an equal or more than
three-fold increase in protein
expression post Baseline compared to pre
in patients with gvhd
um and the um other analysis We
performed was a pair t-test followed by
logistic regression after which we
identified candidate protein biomarkers
of significance so this was with the
individualized analysis this heat map
demonstrates which proteins were
significant and had a more than
threefold increase
um
just before development of graft versus
host disease compared to controls
and in the the the
logistic uh regression analysis was
performed on these proteins
which were found to be most significant
based on paired students t-test
and ultimately gave us these four
proteins of significance
btn3a2 slam F7 il1 ra and dab2 so all
four of these had a um significant
predictive value in regards to
prediction of onset of acute gbhd
um and interestingly all four of these
are proteins that are somehow related to
immune responses
um slime family number seven
um is found on uh it's a receptor that
is a significant and innate and adaptive
immunity and up regulated in immune
diseases uh in autoimmune diseases
um interleukin-1 receptor antagonist is
the naturally occurring antagonist uh to
pro-inflammatory cytokines il1 Alpha and
beta
subfamily three member A2 is the
transmembrane molecule it belongs to the
immunoglobulin superfamily and is
expressed on most human immune cells and
dob2 is a protein that may be involved
in the development of immunological
Tolerance and anti-inflammatory
responses
and what we found was combining these
four into a four marker uh panel the AUC
of this combined panel was quite uh high
at 0.903
um and quite significant as well
so next steps regarding our research is
um validation of course in a larger
cohort which is something that is
currently
um underway
um we have added uh patients to our
cohort and we would like to investigate
further looking at a larger more
extensive o-link panel involving 3000
proteins
um ultimately we would like to focus on
a limited custom panel where having
identified some proteins of significance
we can use them as an early predictor of
acute gvhd that could be widely
applicable
um not just in our cohort but um in the
multiple transplant centers as well
in conclusion biomarker research
continues to be an exciting and dynamic
field and a little genetic transplant
and gvhd research serum protein
biomarkers may prove to be a promising
clinical tool but there is much more
work that remains to be done
and um at this point I'd like to thank
Dr pasig my collaborator as well as um
Dr Ram Nepal Theory and the team at
Mount Sinai Hospital next door to us
that's uh Dr damandis who is the
director of the biochemistry lab and his
collaborators uh Dr prasas and Annie
Wren thank you very much for your
attention
thank you very much for a very
interesting talk
um for those of you who have may have
questions there is a q a box that you
can feel free to submit questions
um I had one uh you showed some early
work right two ra with tnf R1 and il-8
um was that those particular markers
much further down in the treatment
course and then your particular markers
are for the early predictors is that
correct
um sorry can you say can you say that
question one more time sure so in an
earlier paper uh from like earlier
markers there were markers such as il-2
ra and tnf and il-8 that were like
predictors around the severity of of uh
graph versus host and in your work were
the samples that you tested earlier in
the disease course
thus you got different markers
um
that's uh so these particular markers
they they didn't stand out they're well
they're well-known inflammatory
cytokines
um the time points that we chose
the time points that we chose were
calendar driven
um we we didn't collect samples at onset
of uh or
um onset of treatment or at diagnosis of
graph resources like some of these other
studies
um uh so so
as an exploratory study we just wanted
to look at
um potential biomarkers that really we
would see a very significant difference
in expression
that stand out that potentially we can
we can focus on these biomarkers that
you mentioned aren't ones that stood out
so
um well compared to the biomarkers that
we identified
um
it's a different cohort of patience it
might not just be related to different
time points it's a different cohort of
patients different diseases there are a
lot of confounding factors
um which which is what makes biomarker
Discovery really difficult what I think
helps us determine that we're on the
right track at least is that the
biomarkers that we identify that stood
out are immune mediated are immune
related they're related to the immune
system for the most part and
um some of them are pro pro-inflammatory
but the purpose of our study is to
investigate potential proteins using
this Multiplex panel that other
researchers have have never even looked
at
um right it's a little bit of a phishing
Expedition but I guess it is the only
way to to Really identify
um A A A protein biomarker that would
not otherwise have been a identified and
it is good to see that what we have
identified
um biologically it does make sense
yeah the uh I mean it was interesting
right you're going back into the
literature and showing prior work and
intensive work being done and now you
made it clear right this is sort of
after diagnosis after treatment course
has begun right whereas you're looking
at you know a very different scenario
where it's very early on in the disease
course or meaning right after uh like
you mentioned calendar driven a calendar
driven meaning a certain number of days
post-transplantation then you take
samples is that correct
yeah I mean some of the studies I
previously mentioned do focus on certain
time points like day 14 or 30 days
exactly right
um basically we're we're doing the same
thing uh but what what we really want to
do ultimately is identify biomarkers
that can be drawn at day 14 or maybe day
21 after transplant even while the
patient is still inpatient that can
tolerate the patient is very likely to
develop graft versus host disease and
thus help us
determine certain interventions that we
can do to prevent that from from
happening
yep and there you talk about this oh go
ahead
sorry go on
oh there that's true personalized
medicine right where you're actually
looking at the response of the host
right in response to potential danger
and relative risk I mean that was you
know quite informative and yet in terms
of some of the graphs that you showed as
far as risk
um at different levels but nonetheless
the Discrimination wasn't 100 right
no it was it was not 100 but um
that's why that's why I believe that
possibly a panel it's not just one
specific biomarker that's gonna be the
Magic The Magic Bullet right
right and this idea of multiplexed or
multiplexing right uh the prior work
done by single Plex allisas it naturally
limits how many markers you can look at
the same time whereas with the scalable
technology we're able to actually look
at multiple markers here you have four
you mentioned intending to naturally
validate this as well as expand the sort
of net by which you're fishing with
right but nonetheless you know this is
uh very Illuminating in terms of the
scope of the problem when I saw you know
15 to 20 percent mortality
wow you know you're working on a a
problem that has clear impact right in
terms of literally hundreds and
thousands of individuals right who have
this chronic condition so any final
comments you'd like to make
um yeah I mean the the
um prediction of post-transplant
outcomes and particularly graft versus
host disease it's kind of like the Holy
Grail of our field and see these
numerous studies are published and in
some centers are validated in other
centers
um the ability isn't that great
um you know the search is ongoing for
the perfect
um biomarker like I mentioned previously
I don't believe that it will be just one
protein it's very possible it would be a
combination of proteins
the usefulness and Multiplex proteomics
is in the initial phase I believe the
the investigation of the discovery phase
but ultimately you
you cannot
um analyze thousands of proteins and and
you know use this yeah as as uh
fingerprint alone of What patients are
going to
um
um uh how they're going to react and and
respond to treatment I think a handful
of proteins in a limited panel is
probably what um what we're striving for
uh going forward but the multiplex in
the initial phase
um without without that there could be
proteins
um out there that
um are are potentially useful and they
can go undetected
yep which is why we're I think at a
flipping or an inflection point in terms
of interest in protein biomarkers again
after all the work in genomics now
people can take a look at the
circulating proteome in a new way that
actually is scalable by that I mean from
the point of view of finding new markers
right in terms of of so many markers are
still yet to be characterized I mean the
four that you brought up I'm completely
unfamiliar with right in terms of BTN
and slam F7 and and dab and I just like
wow you know that's really really
interesting from a biological point of
view but from a sort of potential
diagnostic point of view really exciting
times uh because right the power of
being able to discriminate in the
prognostic sense early on in the disease
where right treatment courses there's
plenty of different treatments I mean
you went through so many of them that
there's lots of different ways to uh to
go with this once the data is in hand
right do you go aggressive on the
treatment do you give it a light touch
with all the attendant
um side effects or What complications
right being able to choose a simpler
course of treatment
well thank you Frank for just a really
interesting talk thank you audience for
attending today certainly if you're
interested in all link um it's olync.com
and take a look there uh lab Roots I
want to thank lab roots for hosting this
webinar today and have a great day
thank you very much Dale thank you all